d'abord plus de justice et d'égalité
dans le service national avant le
service
les exemptions seront moins nombreuses
fini les distorsions choquant dans la
sélection pendant le service
plus de planquer dans les bureaux
passage obligatoire dans les unités de
combat pour la plupart des appelés et
puis plusieurs mesures vont modifier le
style de vie des soldats du contingent
pourra maintenant lire dans les casernes
presque tous les journaux 250
publications étaient interdites comme
par exemple l'humanité il n'en restera
qu'une dizaine celle qui professent un
antimilitarisme systématique les
permissions seront mieux répartis et les
appeler se verront confier au sein des
unités de véritables postes de
responsabilité notamment dans les
domaines administratif et technique
enfin le service national sera rendu
plus attrayant monsieur souffler veut
des en caserne et en développant les
activités de plein air et les sports de
masse un véritable retour à la nature
pour les bidasses qui ne rentreront pas
à la maison les mains vides ils pourront
obtenir des brevets de natation et de
secourisme et convertir gratuitement
leur permis de conduire militaire en
permission ville le ministre de la
défense souhaite aussi rapprochés
l'armée de la nation en multipliant les
opérations portes ouvertes tant pour les
élus municipaux que pour les familles
des soldats